up on the app right now for the first
time ever exclusively tan mom music
video here look at the screen Robin all
our new technology we can they are there
in a pool it's an amazing video there in
a pool wearing masks but why are they in
a pool and then there's another shot at
an mom where she's covered in smoke and
then do you see an Adam and Tim mama
walking around you see Adam has a giant
king's scepter oh yeah yeah that now
yeah what is that I don't know I mean
why is he carrying is he a king like
there was a story here I just haven't
figured it out yet okay keep playing
[Music]
she's free
[Music]
you
and
[Music]
now they're back in the water all I want
[Music]
oh that's the line that trust me alright
you better stop because I do you see how
hypnotizing it is like you're not even
talking you're busy watching it I can't
believe it yeah you're like hypnotized
you can't believe it you notice in the
video to everyone is some sort of pool
party there's a pool and a party going
on and there's a smoke machine that
completely obliterates them and then
when they are walking around the people
at the party seem to be shooting tan mom
dirty looks
yes because I told you she feels that
the world doesn't understand her I know
but Anna Bardo appears to somehow he's
always there don't we understand this is
all about tan mom that's her beef with
the video but there's too much Adam but
Adams got to be in it he's the one
singing I understand that but if
somebody's gonna be obscured by smoke
you think it should be play 30 more
seconds I can't play you the whole thing
you got to get the app
we're back in the polls all right stop
it much as I want to watch this with you
you got it that's the that's the bottom
line that's the takeaway on the phone is
Adam Barta who stars in the Tan mom
video that probably the brains behind
the Tan mom video why are you running
around with a scepter in the video what
is that so the video is so is so
intellectual on so many levels because
if you if you really at first of all I
think we were high when we wrote this
script but so that probably explains a
lot of it but you know it's basically
hand mom's in a dream world
oh he's living in a dream and you know
I'm kind of like the spirit guide this
lead on the whole the whole universe of
what tan mom is and the humiliation that
she suffered and the triumph that she's
rising I mean there's so much subtext in
this video if you watch it good alright
word you didn't get the subdued no I
didn't actually now I'm gonna go back
and watch it again
[Music]